now I know you know how I knew I'd
always known you but I never really was
that I was little probably mean to you
do you think I've been the same whereas
like probably likes me yeah well I know
you weren't me because one day I said
Bobby can I have $100 and he said for
what in essence one $100 that you gave
me $100 I wouldn't do that with somebody
that didn't like yeah I've always liked
you and here's how you became oh I
became aware of you yeah
years ago Jordan before they did Keanu
he goes hey you want to go Wimmer I once
watched that movie ex machina yeah so
Jordan and we had dinner and then we
were in the theater about to watch ex
machina and he goes you know I'm doing a
movie called Keanu because there's
nothing in it for you
that's the first thing he said which is
fine but it's fine and he goes but tell
me about tomorrow neighbors hmm
and I go what he's crazy so funny though
what a funny guy and and and Jordan goes
yeah I'm thinking about having a minutes
the movie but he you were even in his
eyesight really and when Jordan said
that to me I went he just became
ingrained in my psyche and then a couple
years later we did what would Diplo do
yeah and that's when we work together
yeah yeah yeah but we didn't we were on
the same project but we didn't work
together I only worked with James man
but when you say just say that we were
together work together yes so that
because then you have to explain like
because my character was not really real
I was a ghost right you were go and Jen
and Diplo james van der beek don't see
me yeah woulda see yeah yeah no we
didn't work did you like that show I
love that show people really love it
yeah they really did yeah
do people still talk to you about that
yeah people go I think that if it was on
a different platform it would have
really blown up absolutely I mean it's
perfect for Netflix it's so social like
that yeah
it was so silly and so original and it
it was just on maybe vice land just
wasn't and also Brandon Dermer is the
first director I've ever had really that
basically said you can just do whatever
you want
pretty much yeah so I would do it the
way was written but then I would have
feels so much freedom in terms of trying
different things I really liked doing it
I love James Van Der Beek I like you I
love everyone involved in the thing and
then of course when you don't when
you're in love with something it goes
away it doesn't happen you know I think
it could have been a success dude what
happens when it does it just die then or
does it have like a chance it's all
right now isn't it yeah yeah but I mean
it's if you googled like if you were new
and you searched it but it's not gonna
pop up in their main right you know you
go to comedy there's like fifty thousand
things that come up before diplo but